كنا ندير شركاء ، والآن نحن
شركاء حياة ، اسمي أنتوني بتلر ،
31 عامًا ، ولدت وترعرعت في مدينة نيويورك ،
أصبت بالعمى في سبتمبر من عام 2008 ، كنت
أقيم في برونكس ، حيث كان هناك بعض
الرجال الذين ساروا وأعتقد أنهم
سيذهبون  ابتعد معه عندما
أخرجت مسدسًا أطلق النار علي مرتين أولاً كنت
أفكر أنني كنت ميتًا ، كما تعلم بعد
إصابتي برصاصة في الرأس ، فأنا في
سيارة الإسعاف أفكر كرجل ،
هذا ما سأفعله  تموت
والطبيب كما تعلم ، ربما
لن يتمكن أبدًا من رؤيتك مرة أخرى عندما خرجت ،
كنت تمامًا كما لو أنني تمكنت من تحقيق
أقصى استفادة منها في اليوم التالي ، ذهبت إلى حفلة
كان لدي رصاصة في رأسي أعجبتني  شاش
حول وجهي ،
اسمي جيسي ريكس ، التقينا لأول مرة من
خلال مجموعة ركض تسمى Achilles
international ، وهي تجمع بين العدائين الأصحاء
مع ذوي الإعاقة ، لذا
انضممت كمتطوع أتذكر
رؤيته عندما وصلت إلى هناك لأول مرة لأنه
ربما كان  بصوت عالٍ
هناك مثل وجود مثل الكتابة  من
حياته ويضحك ويتحدث ويبدو أنك
مجرد شخص ممتع لتذهب للركض
معه ولهذا السبب نحب عام 2014 أعتقد أنني
كنت أبحث فقط عن المزيد من الأشياء للقيام بها
كنت أحاول الذهاب إلى صالة الألعاب الرياضية مع
بعض  أصدقائي أو ما
كانوا غير موثوق بهم ، لم أكن أعرف حقًا
كيف أكون معاقًا ، لم أكن أعرف ما إذا كان بإمكاني ممارسة
الرياضة ولكن دعني أدخل هناك بنفسي
لم أكن أعرف ما إذا كانوا سيساعدونني ،
أردت أن أكون في الجوار  الأشخاص الذين كانوا
يعيشون مع ظروف مثل لي مم-همم ،
نوجههم بالريش في بعض الأحيان
نستخدم خيوط الأحذية إلى حد كبير
أي شيء يمكننا أن نتمسك
به ، أبذل قصارى جهدي لاستدعاء ما إذا كانت هناك
فروع معلقة منخفضة ، اذهب للقتال
بقوة  كان الشيء بالنسبة لي عندما
بدأت مع Achilles هو مجرد
فهم كيفية التفاعل بشكل صحيح
مع الأشخاص المكفوفين أو الذين
يعانون من إعاقة أخرى مع التأكد من أنني أخبر
أنطوني بما يحيط به حتى يتمكن من
تجربة الجري معي قدر
الإمكان ما هذا
لقد استغرقنا وقتنا حقًا في البناء
صداقتنا وبناء
علاقتنا وكان الكثير من ذلك من
خلال أخيل ومن خلال الجري
وشغفنا لذلك كنت أعرف أن جيسي
ستكون موثوقة في ظل
أنها ستكون نكران الذات إذا كانت
ستتبعه في
الجري.  كأنها شخص يمكنني
الاعتماد عليه ، فهي شخص يمكن الاعتماد عليه ،
إنها شخص غير أناني ، وتلك
مثل بعض الخصائص التي
تبحث عنها لشخص تريده حتى الآن
، تعلمت التواصل بشكل
أفضل وتعلمت أن
أفهمه  أفضل بكثير كعداء
وكشخص ، فإن الشيء الأكثر مكافأة
بالنسبة لي هو مجرد الأشياء
التي جربتها لم أكن على
متن طائرة مع أي من والديّ
ولم أكن في إجازة عائلية أبدًا  وفي
يوم من الأيام ، كنت أحتاج فقط إلى الحصول على جواز سفري ،
لذا مثل المرات الوحيدة التي
كنت فيها خارج البلد ، كان الأمر كما لو كان الأمر
مع أشخاص من Achilles لم أكن
لأتمكن من رؤية كولتون كولت
لعدم وجود كلمة أفضل  الكثير من
ر  أشياء رأيتها أو اختبرتها في هذا
العالم إذا لم يكن للجري